are you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a Ral I've
asked you two questions should Hamas
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight I'm on Pi Morgan uncensored
he's a Hollywood hero who swapped the
red carpet for the front line of a war
two-time Oscar winner Shawn Penn for the
hour and
[Music]
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to another uncensored
Blockbuster Shawn Penn oneon-one he's an
actor a filmm maker an all around
Hollywood badass I'm talking to you
talking to me yeah on the big screen my
name is Hy milk and I'm here to recruit
you he's one flais and two
Oscars I I did I did not expect this for
his powerful performances is
my he's won both fans and enemies for
his powerful political views Sean Penn
is an arrogant and self-involved person
is latest movie is a documentary
superpower which charts Russia's brutal
war on Ukraine Penn found himself
trapped in ke on the very day Putin's
forces invaded where he came face to
face with a president under
siege now with a new war raging in the
Middle East is a powerful message for
the world it's emotional
thought-provoking controversial it's all
very sha pen and is very unsensed and
Shan pen joins me now Sean great to see
you it's been quite a while 10 years
years I think since I last interviewed
you yeah about that we're in a world of
self-identity are you here identifying
as an actor a humanitarian an activist
or something else good qu I suppose I'm
here identifying as somebody who'd like
to get eyes and ears on this film
superpower and and uh and a continued
conversation on our obligations to
Ukraine the the film I've watched it
twice I think it's a great film thank
you and it couldn't be more timely
because due to events in the Middle East
with the Israel Hamas War a lot of
global attention has moved away from
Ukraine and president zalinski who I
know you know well and I went to ke and
interviewed him myself is very concerned
that while the world looks away Vladimir
Putin will accelerate his attempt to
effectively take as much of Ukraine as
he can get how perilous do you think
this moment is for
Ukraine I think the way I equate it is
how perilous is it for mankind in our
General
um Mission Focus be that with our
families or with the World At
Large there are not too many
distractions available to get us off
course if we don't let there be the
concerns in the Middle East are of
course very real and
great but with with the principles
intact that those in the world who
believe in in Freedom whether whether
you call it democracy or something
else we're not given more to do than
we're able to do and I think it's just
the the the micro stuff and the breaking
down of each other in all of this is
really the distraction that we should
worry about obviously that's manipulated
by enemies it was never I never felt
that for example President Putin's trip
to Tran was strictly about drones and I
do believe that there was an influence
on what happened October 7th uh in Gaza
and in
Israel uh that that that that too was
influenced by this so these things have
connections and and so to defeat those
things and for freedom to Triumph is to
be able to maintain focus on both and
the other issues of the day do you see
parallels between what's happening in
Israel and Gaza and the Ukraine Russia
War well of course there are certain
parallels um you you know
the the want and disregard for and in
fact proactive attack on civilians on
children on
infrastructure and and the biggest
parallel I suppose the most the one I
think we could spend our time most
productively focusing
on
is the way in which and this extends to
so much else the way in which uh new
Nuance is not allowed into the
conversation now what's not a parallel
in the case of you know what's not
nuanced at all in the Ukraine Russia
conflict or rather Russia's criminal
invasion of
Ukraine is that's a very um
unambiguous set of circumstances it's a
very clear um black hat involved here a
black hat against all our human
principles with Russia
horrible and and and misguided Invasion
and all the murder and all of the taking
of children and re-educating of children
to hate their parents and their country
and things we just shouldn't stand for
as any s single section of
it my sense is that and I'm not an
expert on the Middle East but my sense
is certainly that there with the horror
of what Hamas has done that to get to a
productive result
for Jews for Israelis for Arabs in
Israel for Arabs in Gaza and the West
Bank and and around the Middle
East we might not like it but it's going
to take a very nuanced conversation and
and and and the sooner we get to it the
better and the more push there is or
resistance to that conversation it will
historic the Legacy will be that those
who pushed against the nuanced
conversation would have been the ones to
have extended the problem you recently
told variety magazine before what's just
blown up in in the Middle East if you'd
been US president after 9911 you'd have
done things differently you said if I
have to go to prison I'll go but I'm
going to kill them I'm killing everyone
that did this but only them and we know
where the fers they are where the F they
are in the context of that gut response
that you had to 9/11 do you understand
why Israel has reacted the way it's done
even if you don't endorse it but you
understand their desire their fervent
need as a country to go after Hamas and
eliminate the people that perpetrated
the the terror attack were Hamas living
in remote mountains of Tabor I I I would
have absolutely understood it but when
you have a place like you know
topographically similar let's say it's
Malibu California and size and scope and
Al though aund times more populated you
know when we think of God we do have to
understand Tak without taking a side
being a Defender apologist for
anything those children are hearing
every gunshot throughout the country
yeah are feeling every ordinance that
drops this is
247 it's this is a tiny Place packed
with people that's very diff I I I would
say absolutely I would like to see Hamas
evaporated in mountains like torab Bor
as perhaps could have Al Qaeda at that
time if you do a a constant bombardment
for many weeks is the way the Israelis
have done you're going to kill thousands
and thousands of completely innocent
children and I find that morally
repugnant that that's happening and yet
I defend their moral right to go after
Hamas it's it's a really it's a
difficult situation isn't it it's very
difficult and of course one has to be
very aware you know what that could have
been my my daughter or son at that music
festival for example I mean it I
understand
the immediate reaction to that even the
longterm reaction to it but again we we
do have to also say well it's somebody
else's children next time and when I
brought up when I said that I felt that
you know that I had a dream that
President Bush might just say I'm
sending the White House Council home
this has to be done we'll suffer the
consequences later in Tor with
ala I also said that I that having done
that he might have licensed himself to
then go back in time and say in what
ways again we know this is these are the
kind of things that people love to chew
apart in what ways did
we was were we complicit in the poverty
in the hopelessness in the oppression of
a people somewhere else in the lack of
inclusivity of those people that
contributed to to to that hatred that
that came our way so in this case too
there's there are the big differences
one is the civilian population of Gaza
and the other
is the that we are told not to speak
about the accountability of Israel and
the United States and their support of
Israel uh in many ways unconditional
support and you know I'm
48% ashkanazi Jew right um I have I
nothing but love for my ancestry and
ancestors that doesn't have anything to
do with the fact that I think that while
Israel's people
were criminally horrifyingly
attacked that Israel also has a prime
minister who is a
terror by any measure of basic political
thinking that's bad timing you think
he's an actual terrorist that well I
didn't say terrorist um I wouldn't
necessarily jump to say that because I
think they I don't know that he's cry
trying to create Terror so much as he's
trying to create an inflated sense of
his own worth in his
time your father the actor director leop
pen uh as you said an American Jew of
Eastern European descent also highly
decorated War veteran he served as a
tail Gunner and bombarder in the B24
Liberator with the US Air Force in World
War III actually stationed here in
England that's right and of course was
fighting the Nazis which were an
existential threat to civilization at
the time you know many Israelis say what
they're going through now is the worst
existential threat to what happened to
them in the Holocaust um your dad was an
amazing guy life expectancy for the role
that he played in that war with seven
missions he did 37 he did is that where
you get this a spirit
from uh I I would only aspire to it um
I've never been tested like that uh yeah
but he is uh the hero in my uh my
experience yeah what would he what would
he do you think have made of what's
Happening Now with Israel and what
advice would he give them do you think
to try and get to a better
place my dad used to have an expression
when I would come home very opinionated
on one issue or another and very angry
at anyone one who believed differently
he would say you know everyone has their
own Truth Kid and I think his advice
would be for people to recognize what is
true of each other's position and then
it's also important to recognize what is
a lie that one that that group thinkers
tell themselves to be comfortable and to
have a group and an identity and I think
this extends again to the the broader
cultural picture of a lot of What's um
distracting from us getting down to the
things that will help help our world be
better we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online run your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call Ham a terror group
is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a m in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love purgy we can agree
on
[Music]
that you've been very scathing of
America's lack of what you think is
proper support particularly with Ukraine
with regard to their ability to control
the air you would like to have seen
America Supply X F-16 Fighters and so on
why do you feel so strongly about that
we need to step up every day is another
opportunity um the ukrainians are
certainly uh ready to fight the fight
they've never asked for our troops to be
on the ground or in the air and there's
been a lot of sort of smoke and mirror
talk about how long it would take
whether there were the maintenance Crews
available there there's actually been
workarounds available on that from the
very beginning and and within the first
months of the war there could have been
f-16s without also there's a betrayal of
the ukrainians with nuclear weapons we
made them give theirs up if they had had
those nuclear weapons I don't think
Putin would have countenanced invading
but he knew he could invade a
non-nuclear power with impunity but if
they' been able to keep their weapons
they wouldn't have been a non-nuclear
power and and Americans should know
particularly you know we did sign the
Budapest memorandum and that did assure
Ukraine that if they gave up those
weapons Russia the United States and the
other and the others involved would
never even
threaten uh intervention or violence
against the country I've got a clip this
is from a 2001 Moscow Film Festival you
and Jack Nicholson actually meeting
Vladimir Putin have you been to
Russia in 2001 Jack Nicholson and I had
a film at the Moscow Film
Festival that night has become a deviant
memory a deviant memory what is your
memory of that
meeting I remember this was
approximately two weeks after the famous
meeting between President Bush and and
Putin um where President Bush said
something like you know I looked him in
the eye and I knew I could trust him I I
didn't come away with a great uh I don't
mean a good or bad impression a deep
impression at the time he was U you know
a a a bit of a a a poker-faced fellow uh
talked about his kids there was there
were no politics discussed per se but
when I talk about it as a deviant memory
you know I look at
that and now you know World head of
state aside World politics aside I'm
looking at somebody
who's you know cutting off baby heads I
don't like having been next to that I
don't know if you've got it on you now
but for a long time you carried a card
in your wallet uh by the great Armenian
American Author William serin and there
was a quote from this I think part of a
lengthier quote but there's a bit that
says despise evil and ungodliness but
not men of ungodliness or evil these
understand have no shame in being kindly
and gentle but if the time comes in the
time of your life to kill kill and have
no regret it's a powerful quote it is
yeah I don't think I knew what it meant
really until like I said as you said I
carried that around forever it made some
visceral impact on me and I could tell I
could recognize the kind of the rhythm
of the thoughts in a way that was
provocative more provocative to say than
anything i' I'd read in a short form
like that and so I I I kept it with me
thinking I knew what it meant but sort
of like the way an onion gets peeled it
wasn't until I got to Ukraine where I
really felt like okay now I understand
this thing does any part of you
understand as he wrote there about put
clearly a man of evil many would say I
certainly would um but if you're playing
Devil's Advocate trying to get into his
brain do you understand why this guy
thought the breakup of the Soviet Union
was the worst thing that's ever happened
to his country felt like the NATO
encroachment as he saw it closer and
closer to the Russian border was a
threat to the Russian people I mean does
any part of that make any sense to you
or do you think it's just an excuse for
his land grab
it's what I call kind of the bulb no
bulb people you see the light of
humanity in some
people I I I so whatever the sort of
speculation is and I've read some of the
histories of Putin and seen some of the
documentaries and I've certainly
listened to better brains than mine uh
talk about that and sort of analyze
him I think essentially what this is is
an unimagined
person someone who whose bulb either
never got fully put on and therefore was
not distracted by the colors of life
that the rest of us uh Embrace Donald
Trump says he would resolve this war in
24 hours I think in the United States
Donald Trump is guilty most of being a
um
adolescent
uh um
influencer of cheap cheap
thought and cheap thought is very
expensive it's it again I go back to
what America should be searching for and
a democrat or a republican it's an
aspirational figure not someone you hang
your your lowest denominator you went on
Sean Hannity show on Fox News which I
thought was a really interesting moment
when you did that that's a big deal for
you to do that you're going into what I
guess would have been historically a
kind of media enemy L yeah but you were
prepared to do that to have that debate
and it was a very interesting interview
actually while there's incredible
influence by media figures by political
figures um if somebody has had no
experience with real bomb throwers
perhaps they should hold that that
phrase and come up with something uh
more particular to what their concern is
because it it just makes it again an EXT
it's a
you know exaggerated and or or or just a
perversion of what's really going
on I don't know about you but most
people I talk to once you get it off the
standard conversation of policy or
personality around the world they want
the same thing they want a better world
for themselves and their family tomorrow
they want education for their kids it's
it's the most common and they could be
quite reasonable however unreasonable
they may have sounded and you get when
you get past that you can have a what
used to be perfectly normal conversation
in a free Democratic Society right but
now we're in a world where cancel
culture is a very real thing right and
you know you know better than anyone the
dangers of this what happened to your
father who was ostracized by Hollywood
when he wouldn't throw his friends under
the bus when there was that huge you
know what was it the the big
investigation into whether whether they
were Communists or whatever it may be he
refused to take part in that and he
never really got his career back as a
result that was cancel culture and of
course he played Harvey Milk again a
perfect illustration of what a world can
do when it wants to cancel people now
it's so much more prevalent now yeah
it's like people get canceled for having
an opinion just saying what they
honestly believe about stuff yeah how
have we got
there I I say I would you know I'm a
little bit borrowing from Step fry here
he he he gives this great closing
argument at the end of monk debate on
political correctness and I
think maybe and it will seem ironic that
that I respond this way maybe we've
taken ourselves too
seriously and have you
included uh perhaps at the Forefront
many
times he said that you fly a big
American and Ukrainian flag at your home
in Malibu he said I'm a big proponent of
the idea we start waving flags again
even if we're on the left and we don't
worry that our neighbors are going to
think we suddenly became a Maga hor
which is what some of my friends accuse
me of just for having an American flag
flying yeah but again that apparently is
now offensive the left will the left a
lot of friends of
mine well you know we got to take the
flag back
or we got to share it again yes yes I
mean it's interesting isn't it that
countries find true Unity often in the
worst possible circumstance I felt that
when I went to New York after 911 it
felt like the whole country was United
in that moment in a way I hadn't seen
America probably in my lifetime
similarly I think you know you had the
same experience with Haiti and how the
Haitians came together I certainly felt
it I think you did in Ukraine that the
Ukrainian people were just almost
completely as one in in their desire to
save their country Reserve their freedom
back their president that wasn't the
case before the war started no but all
the more I mean as important as our
support of them to to to dominate this
to to return their freedom and
sovereignty to themselves and to rebuild
their country is is the long-term plan
this is the opportunity for mankind for
all freeth thinking why can't we
unify that we remember that once that's
resolved we have to have the spirit and
resources in place for it to be the
example of it continuing Beyond them
unified under war that was the question
leading example why do we find it so
hard to continue the unity when we get
back to a more peaceful time I think I
think unities are cannibalized first by
those who are promoting
Unity I think we' you know things blow
up from the inside of an idea and you
know I think even I think even with the
in the case of Russia uh after
1994 you know I remember the relief the
Cold War is Over
people are dancing I never I don't think
we ever looked back and noticed that the
Russians were not feeling the relief
that the world was feeling and that
gangsterism had replaced communism and
the breadlines were just as long and
they were it would things didn't get
better for them and you let that happen
over time and somebody like Putin is
able to come back take power and do what
he's doing we need strong leadership
never more so than from America does it
worry you the thought that Trump may win
again because nothing they're throwing
at him seems to make any difference in
fact it all seems to increase his
popularity all these indictments and so
on I know there's a lot of speculation
that he may and a lot of speculation
that he may not I think that my concern
would if I could I'd like an x-ray of
who we are in America today is that
really possible because before Trump
that would be the problem if we if we're
still ready to let every everything we
stand for and everything my father's
generation and those before stood for
and I don't mean that they accomplished
all their tasks for everybody we know
that never happened and that we hope it
still can but if we go soft and yellow
and decide we're going to let it go and
let this guy as judge sud once said take
the ball and roll with it
um then you know I'm going to have to
find my pride in a glass of
vodka i' take more than one glass of
vodka
sure we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about talk today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
assing for a livit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prep to call teror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV let's talk about
superpower it's fascinating to me that
this began this movie as a much lighter
film that you wanted to make about this
extraordinary story of a guy who was an
actor a comedic actor predominant um you
know he'd been seen playing the piano
with his penis on a special on TV for
the delectation of Ukrainian people and
they all laughed um then he takes part
in this in this series called servant of
the people where as a comedic actor he
ends up becoming president of Ukraine
right and we got a
clip
foree
[Music]
fore
such a powerful clip that because it's
so preent because this guy then becomes
the real president of Ukraine and very
quickly has a very bad guy and other bad
guys coming to take his country yeah uh
it's and that in that moment your whole
film that you've been making which is a
light fun look at a guy who's a comedy
actor and you're an actor and you think
this is fun and then it gets incredibly
serious and you as a filmmaker but you
as an actor what did you make of all
this well personally it it's one more
time where I could say you know I try to
be light and P me back in you know we
here we really did albertino go f suck
me back in yeah um you know it's
interesting and I take it back a little
bit to when we're talking about
President Biden it it is
there's a you know this is somebody who
has an extraordinary person of service
for so long understands the game very
deeply the process the bureaucratic
process and I think has a lot to offer
this situation was it was so um you know
we met president zinski the first time I
had I had said because of what I thought
could be a value added documentary that
I could make versus some accomplished
documentarian or
journalist uh that that that it's always
been a kind of a trust and
trustworthiness Bond and maybe it would
be a different kind of conversation I
don't and therefore I didn't want to
have a camera available the first time
we we met face to face and it was just a
crazy Coincidence of timing that we met
the first time on the 23rd without a
camera literally the day before the war
starts right and agreed that on the 24th
we do our first session with the camera
and unbelievably he sees you he he
fulfilled the commitment despite the
Rockets coming in we've got a clip of
[Music]
this home where where does it end what
does he want what does he what is the he
wants to he wants he wants us to be dead
he he he hate you he he hate us I we we
don't know
why I mean it's incredible the war
starts and he takes time to see you and
no offense but sha Penn you're an actor
were you surprised he kept that meeting
and why do you think he did I was
surprised of course I'm was surprised um
you know we were all processing um the
tragedy of of this unimaginable decision
Putin's
um today I I understand it better uh I
think he's
very Savvy uh I think that any
opportunity to have a record
of I think he believed in what he was
going to do and what his people were
going to do so much so that in a country
at
War we were never uh watched over when
we were shooting we never had a minder
there was never a word of influencing
anything really he knew how important
America would be and he thought using a
Hollywood Superstar osc multiple Oscar
winner would shine a light right when he
needed it to get help from America
that's that's a guy understands the
media understands politics possibly from
playing a president in a comedy I mean
it's surreal the way you guys came
together like this yeah and another way
to look at it is you you know when I'm
remember I've been very focused and had
a lot of responsibility I'm not
comparing it to the responsibility he
has but but I've had responsibilities in
certain situations to a lot of people
and sometimes to their physical
well-being and uh you know you do find
that moment where your bandwidth needs
to step outside and have a cigarette it
may be that you know he used this
opportunity obious say he stepped
outside essentially had a cigarette yeah
uh you know it doesn't mean that it's
like he took time out of fighting award
he was also sh at the time on that day
the number one Target in the country for
Putin it was a moment when you go to the
front line this is about four months
later and a woman says this to you it's
uh about 10 kilm from zero position
that's the
priority can I be very blunt you're Shan
pan nobody's going to be responsible for
you dying on the front
line
I mean that's a moment when you hear
that because that's completely true the
front line doesn't care who you are how
many Oscars You've Won you end up 150
meters away from Russians across a river
um notwithstanding you've been in a few
hairy situations in your life that that
must have been a seriously unnerving
moment wasn't it of course I took a deep
breath at some point before we went in
but I I also felt that you know and
what's here um uh I think graciously
that that voice who was uh working as a
translator with us she she you know
offered an abund abundance of caution um
but again it's almost an embarrassing
thing to I understand the question and
you know there's some versions of of
this I could say differently but you
know when when I think
of people who are staying there in that
fight uh you know versus parachuting in
for a second and getting a little a
little bit of a story and and going out
I I don't really know how to talk about
that there's a moment when you go to an
apartment block this is in your first
visit after the war started in June and
you see the devastation for yourself of
this air strike that had happened just a
few hours before and what was
particularly telling for me uh as I
watched you do this was I suddenly
realized that this was the same
apartment block I'd gone to a month
after you when I did a show or two shows
from from keeve and walked in I'm pretty
sure the same apartment block um and I
don't know how you felt when I but I I
felt just i' never been in that kind of
I'm not a war correspondent I don't
normally go to places like this and just
to see the utter Devastation of just in
that case one person's life it's not
just front line Soldier to Soldier it is
the constant barrage of civilian life
and Ordinary People families that have
been separated for two years while the
men stay to to fight the fight or
support the fight in in country and the
mothers and the children who are spread
out all over the world some you know
with no promise of anywhere or any to go
or any support and in some cases getting
you know otherw worldly support Poland
in particular was you both the civilians
and the leadership were extraordinary uh
toward them uh but still that's walking
out into a Brave New World and and you
know just worrying every day about your
brother or your father son who's in the
fight you dedicated the film to
Ukrainian fighter pilot known as juice
he was the leader of the Fable ghost of
Kiev unit which didn't actually exist in
the way people thought but he was an
unbelievably Good Pilot and he very
sadly died three months ago yeah in a
training exercise you see in the movie
you take him to see top gun Maverick
he's a real life Top Gun you saw it in
Washington he were lobbying for F-16
Jets um and he's now one of the 100,000
ukrainians who died in this war um
including I think 13,000
civilians tell me about him for a moment
I mean the impact he had on your
life well I'd like to say we became
friends we we kept in touch after we
spent time in Washington I I might um
you know we'd be on an encrypted line
that he was okay with and I might you
know say Hey you know what's happening
he said just about to go wheels up and
he'd be because they were they were
constantly in the
fight um
he was a very poetic creature you know
not what you would expect of a Top Gun
essentially Top Gun fire pilot was a
great
leader
he's a guy who
believed he owed his country's service
he's not he was a yeah sort of
personality-wise the furthest thing you
you'd think from a military man and um a
beautiful spirit uh and great humor he
you know most people know that movie Top
Gun Maverick and when we were watching
it in DC I was sitting next to him and
he he leaned over at one point after Tom
Cruz had ejected uh and and uh found his
way in his Dusty flight suit to the to
the to the diner and he leaned over and
he said that's why I always take my
wallet how did you how did you find out
that he
died so um somebody I no I don't know I
mean if he would mind my saying his name
you can assume who it is from let's say
the civilian now someone who had worked
in government who would have known
anything the New York Times Knew by the
time the New York Times knew anything
where you collect open- Source material
and a per very credible person um called
me middle of the night and said no
because I'd introduced the two of them
in
DC and knew that I would want to know
and said this happened and then I double
checked it with the ministry of Defense
in Ukraine and they came back and said
yep s
m
yeah what is it but sort of like what
you're talking about with the apartment
right it's it's personalized yeah and
it's personalized tens of thousands of
times
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online onun
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver
the tor's love a scrap you can almost
see this coming around the tracks with
sella bravman she's heading up one side
and richy soon at the other the police
are pro Palestine that is just not right
you swear an o in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan should have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in last three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man mous he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on beh reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love purgy we can agree
on
that
[Music]
you you were angry when the
academy uh just after the war blew up
decided not to let zalinski speak at the
Oscars and then of course that Oscars
became known for the Will Smith Chris
Rock punch up on stage which you don't
think would have happened if zinski had
been allowed to speak because the idea
of someone then committing an act of
violence publicly at the same event
would have been Unthinkable right yeah I
I
mean the there was if what what are
films you know it's not just the cellul
you print them on it's bigger medicine
than that you know it can be uh
and so they ideas there
stories what more cinematic idea or
story is is there or more identified
with film a film star also a filmmaker
zalinski what's more appropriate at that
moment in time to address the Academy
Awards he had no intention of being um
part partisan politics in the United
States it was really
to talk about the value of Cinema and to
thank all of of those around the world
that were supporting and and the academy
that's what he he would have shared and
that they traded that for I guess the
karma of what happened with Will Smith
it it you know you look at Will Smith
whose performance
was great that's King Richard just
I why this Petty kind of thing happens I
was in I was back uh a part of the trip
that was more related to my organization
core back in Ukraine and at this point
in leiv when that happened and I you
know literally I felt were you watching
I feel no I couldn't wasn't watching it
but I heard about it in the morning
after and saw the clip and and I
literally felt something like safer in
Ukraine than Hollywood watching it you
know mentally how it just seemed so
small and when you in your earlier
Incarnation punch somebody you got a
60-day jail sentence served half of it
in prison yeah Will Smith goes back up
to receive the best actor award after
whacking somebody at the Oscars live and
gets an ovation from the audience yeah
that aition should be that that should
be played on this show a lot of times to
because the shame on them you know it
it's so yeah I I just felt that that was
a a very low moment in uh in and
whatever the leadership of the academy
and denying this thing having you know
or the producer of that particular show
being so of of such um lack of substance
uh it was discouraging yeah you um was
so angry about this you wanted to melt
down your two Oscars for bullets for
Ukrainian soldiers to use against the
Russians and in the end you didn't do it
but you gave one of your Oscars to
president zalinski but on loan and he
said when this War's over bring it back
to Malibu we've got a clip of what you'd
like to do when you see him after this
war
ends I hope I really hope that when he's
an old man and I'm an even older one
that I might be sitting with him in a
peaceful and prosperous free
ke laughing like a couple of kids and
what William seran called the infinite
delight and
mystery of
life it's a lovely thought um but you
must have had quite a few moments not
least when you left ke that first time
on the day war had broken out and you
were able to leave and he was left there
that you might never see him again of
course yeah it was a it was it creeped
up on me by surprise because you know
when you're in a when you meet somebody
who's in circumstances that
reasonably could end in any way any way
you can
imagine and where there were such clear
Intentions by you know our it's
understood that there were Chet and kill
squads in the streets of K who were
targeting he and his family at that time
so they it was coming at it from all
angles the potential targeting of
government
buildings snipers everything and that he
was this target you you know you you you
you make a decision faster emotionally
and and I I recognized my affection for
him so I felt I can't speak for him and
as he had a lot of things to respond to
but I felt a a a a friendship at least
from my side like a a bond
and when we left it suddenly hit me what
did I do that for what did I open myself
up to that because I and it was yeah it
was a real uh worry has he seen the
movie yeah as a filmmaker he had the
patience to watch the whole thing and so
we walked into the office this is
sometime after I don't know we made
several trips I'd seen him several times
before this and this was the trip we
were making to show him the a rough cut
for the first time and so he he he saw
it sometime between 600 and 7:00 in the
morning before starting his day and we
saw him at about 4:00 in the afternoon
when we came into the office he's
standing there looking at me and he
said I bet you're glad I watched the
whole
thing I bet you were too yeah I was I
was because you've been accused
obviously there's too much of you in the
movie and so but you make a joke of that
several times you know about you're not
trying to be Walter krony and they liken
you to haral and so on you're you're
seeing that joke but at the same time
you're also aware you wouldn't have got
the movie off first base if you weren't
front and center with this it wouldn't
have happened yeah and you know again it
had to do with recognizing and this was
a process first there was we couldn't
get the financing if I didn't wasn't on
camera very hard these these movies now
there's a great movie called freedom on
fire which is a a companion piece to
Winter on fire by auski who was
nominated for the Academy Award for
winter on fire about the maidon
Revolution and and he he he hasn't been
able to get a distribute for this thing
CU these kinds of films are very
difficult right now I think he just
showed it at the Vatican to the pope and
hopefully some traction will come off of
that but so for us to get this thing
done required me being in it then you
know to I I felt like there again it was
saying what's the value added and of
course I can be mocked in whatever way
but I do think we were really successful
despite in the truth of how people can
benefit from this thing by offering
myself to it in a way that is kind of
like it's kind of one of the so like I
say here I get I've get I've gotten
access to people and things that I know
wouldn't have come without my day job
supporting that and financially as well
as in terms of access to people and
that normally though it might not seem
it to people because I it gets covered I
have tried to avoid covering those trips
and what I'm actually doing and I
thought this time I'm going to let
people come with me and in the editing
it was really important to me I was you
know I make it clear I have opinions big
surprise you've been dipping your toe
back into acting again and you did say
five years ago I'm not in love with that
anymore about acting you falling a bit
back in love with it again well I had an
experience that uh surprised me yeah I
did movie called dadia with Dakota
Johnson directed and written by a woman
named Christy Hall and it was kind of a
gift of a piece just really wonderfully
written thing and
U I hate admitting this part of it but
it was all run by
women better than other jobs I'd been on
really and uh and you sound surprised
sure no just you know embittered of my
original intent to be a you know
misogynist my own life what do you think
of the current world we live in where
people no longer want to say what a
woman is for fear of being cancelled I
can't I'm bored with it I think I think
let's talk about that when people aren't
being vaporized on the front lines and
of wars and you know I I'm might I'm
I'm I'll stay out of judgment on it but
I'm not engaged in the conversation just
seems um not like the
priority the other thing I wanted to ask
you about was the very sad death of
Matthew Perry because you appeared in
several episodes of friends and he
suffered from a lot of addiction issues
he wrote an incredible book about it one
of the most powerful books I've read but
your son Huber had addiction issues and
you talked about that he said you saved
his his life your thoughts about
Matthew what a talented guy I can't
claim to have known him well but I liked
him very much I saw him somewhat
recently and we were both catching a
flight out of Los Angeles airport and I
you know complimented him on um what I
knew of his book I hadn't read the book
I had seen SE several of his interviews
and he seemed to be talking about had
confronted it and and and was very
intelligent and and you know bold about
it and and and generously offering his
experience to people to be helpful um
it's tra it's tragic I can't say that
was terribly surprised I I don't know
what the whole coroners report things
and everything but I know he had done a
lot of damage to his organs over the
years um you know tough tough situation
and you know he got to do that he got to
leave that tail behind and he he got to
give a lot of joy to a lot of people
with his talent and so you know uh I
wish his family well I've tried to
maintain the highest standards of
Journalism for this interview because
you said recently I still don't like
journalism that focuses on what toilet
paper celebrities use out of Interest
what what toilet paper do you use I've
got a rule of Putin face
paper have you really yeah somebody gave
it to me yeah you see sometimes it's
those questions to get the best answers
um and the other thing I couldn't help
but notice because you turned up with
her here is you have a new lady in your
life Olga and she's Ukrainian how did
you how did you guys
meet um my good
luck she's here she is shall I shall I
get her into our
no but you're happy yeah very happy Sean
it's good to see you again great to see
you let's not leave us along long next
[Music]
time
we're here thanks for joining us you
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dark this one
has booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million £1 140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy B Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald's MC Mouse man MC
mous man mous man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz